spicy Mexican eggs
this is a very classic Mexican style
brunch dish bold Kick-Ass flavors slice
the chili seeds in
garlic sliced nice and thinly
tablespoon of olive oil
I'm a big fan of brunches and if you get
it right a great brunch you can see
you're right through to dinner now to
start the sort of spicy fragrant tomato
sauce get your cumin in there
garlic chili roasted cumin red onions
already sounds Mexican
once that starts getting really nice and
crispy in with your tomatoes
never embarrassed using good canned
tomatoes I do it all the time cooking at
home
Now by reducing that sort of come down
to a delicious paste leave that to
simmer
next canned beans called black beans
these are authentically Mexican but
cannellini beans or chickpeas will work
just fine just rinse them a little bit
of water
that is beautiful turn off the gas and
just let it absorb leaving the dense
beans to luxuriate in the spicy tomato
sauce will allow them to soften and soak
up all the flavor
next oil and season and oven proof dish
for my spicy egg crunch to baking
I'll just get some of that oil
around the outside
take your corn tortillas slice them in
half and then just stick them to the
side
these are a staple in Mexico
take one replace that in the center
get your mix
and place that on top of the tortilla
spread that out nice and smoothly lift
up those little flaps I want that crisp
shell on the outside
now your eggs and cheese get the base of
the egg and just make a little hole in
there and then crack
the egg into the
again use a little point
put your egg in there one
two
three
four five and one in the middle
gently crack and get the egg to sit
inside almost like it's a little dug out
and then one for the center
get a really nice rich delicious strong
Montgomery cheddar I want a grape the
tortilla shell as well so get generous
with it on the top and we'll season that
with these little babies
little chili flakes they're my little
secret weapon and they're going to spice
up that egg which is salt
such a pepper
sit that in the oven to bake for eight
to ten minutes and 180.
[Music]
[Applause]
that smells incredible
just a little bit of coriander to finish
it off
and that for me is what brunch is all
about let's go
a fantastic fiery brunch to get your
party started spicy Mexican eggs in a
crispy tortilla shell
mouth-watering Smoky pulled pork with a
spicy chipotle mayonnaise
[Music]
that is the most amazing pork butt
that's the way that's away now this is
incredible there's the shoulder yeah and
look there's the shoulder blade if you
go through here there's a knuckle there
that's connecting the top and that's why
it's called a butt the slow you cook it
the more juice it is and it's great for
big parties because you just come along
and get your fork and shred it a
delicious Smoky mayonnaise and in a way
onions into half and half again okay I'm
Gonna Leave the roots on okay because I
want this to sit underneath the pool
it gives a chance to cook evenly it
doesn't get dry on the bottom really
important okay now I'll peel the garlic
okay I'd like you to crush the garlic
we're going to make a really nice little
paste
okay
[Music]
come on come on come on
nice good girl one more Crush
come on biggie okay
cut there now this
there's a beauty
paprika smoke paprika I love it so three
nice tablespoons in
okay
two large tablespoons of brown sugar
salt please
and pepper good girl
[Laughter]
so I'm going to form a nice paste now
olive oil in
mix that some thyme in there so we got a
sort of fragrant rub time stalks
underneath
so that's even more flavor going on the
bottom
pour that all over it
now
this is where you've got to be really
quick
okay
sort of rub that massage it in almost
that's exactly that
smells amazing we'll see
let's drizzle a little touch of olive
oil on top of that for me
keep the pork nice and moist
lovely like some of the best party
dishes the marinating the pork shoulder
can be done days in advance so if I was
doing this for a Sunday and start
marinating Thursday Friday so it gets
even tastier right it's quite easy as
well to make it's very easy five and a
half to six hours in the oven at 140.
while our pork butt slowly roasts Meg
and I are gonna pimp some shop bought
mayonnaise
I don't like just plain mayonnaise
there's so many things you can twist
yeah there's so many things so many
exciting you can do with it right
salt pepper
and
a little touch of Honey sweetness yeah
sweetness but there's some heat coming
okay and I've got a little bit of you
know this Chipotle smoked Chipotle paste
I love that once you've made this
dressing you know it can sit in the
fridge great for open sandwiches yeah
you can use it for any sandwiches really
any sandwiches but goes brilliantly well
with pork now just have a little taste
I've never had this before it's so good
a nice spoon of mustard
[Music]
that's a nice spicy mayonnaise
after five and a half hours in the oven
our pork is nearly ready just time to
knock up a couple of tried and tested
party favorites first deliciously simple
cheesy crushed potatoes cut potatoes
into even chunks and submerge in salted
boiling water skins and all
meanwhile finally diced sweet pickled
gherkins or cornichons
trim and finely chop spring onions
and Grate some nutty gruya cheese
when the potatoes are cooked through
drain roughly crush and add your spring
onions and gherkins
season to taste and gently combined
before a final sprinkling of grated
Greer
potatoes are equally delicious served
hot or cold
now I want something sort of raw like a
slaw something quite refreshing yeah so
I'm going to make a really nice fresh
broccoli salad now these are called
florets that's the best part of the
broccoli okay the bit everybody wants
once they're off I'm going to slice the
broccoli
okay never had raw broccoli before it's
always been cooked when you dress this
with the dressing it's incredible now
little Seasons early on
yeah okay now for the dressing fresh
yogurt in teaspoon of sugar please die
a little small
cider vinegar there you go
finely chopped it up
in with the broccoli so
delicious
roasted almonds into the broccoli
carrots I love them that gives that nice
sort of chewy texture right lift up your
bowl please nice and gently
half of that in the middle please thank
you and stop and then mix that up with
me
take care
a little taste
so good and it's a kind of salad that
doesn't Wilt a couple of hours later
it's still crunchy because the
broccoli's raw raw broccoli salad
Chipotle now let me get a pork out for
this look at this Megan honestly that is
amazing it's beautiful that is
incredible
[Music]
now that goes to the table like that a
delicious I have a tiny bit just before
we go to the table just a little bit
honestly
don't tell mum thank you
I'm gonna do it
now
so yeah you promised me you don't give
the recipe to your boyfriend let's go
this is my ultimate easy party dinner
melt in your mouth slow cooked Smoky
pulled pork with a spicy chipoli
mayonnaise
I'm quick simple size of crushed cheesy
potatoes and a light and healthy
broccoli slaw deliciously yummy dishes
that will have your family friends and
work buddies coming back for more the
perfect side dish for my fantastic Fried
Chicken
Jack hi mate gonna help with some piglet
please oh definitely no you love pickles
right love pickles um favorite pickle
what is it I like pickled onions we're
gonna do pickled celery it's a nice
little snack and great for plowman's
great for salads first thing I'm going
to pick the celery for me so you see
where the next one's going to be it's in
there yeah okay I'll figure one I'm
hungry today is this all we're having
for dinner Jack come on I wouldn't do
that too you know that there's more
coming now because we're picking it we
want to sort of make it look a little
bit more attractive so we go around like
that okay on an angle so when you pick
all the food does it does it preserve it
that's exactly what it does but also it
gives it a really nice salty soury
flavor yeah okay now a splash of water
and then with the sugar
okay
so we've got to bring that up to the
ball get this little crate almost like a
little syrup yeah okay A little teaspoon
of Peppercorns in mustard seeds in quite
generous on the mustard seeds that gives
a bit of sort of spice now those you
must know
clothes excellent clothes in now Touch
of salt in there okay
so from there white wine vinegar
now in order for all that to actually
pickle you need to boil it so by boiling
it okay it brings all the ingredients
together it chooses all the spices
and
helps cook the celery have a little
taste
see I put some hands on your chest
yes it will look boom it's working
already now see hmm
nice
all right celery is ready yep yep okay
let's go up to the ball now
yeah turn that off
now from there
start placing the celery into that jar
so when you pick one other foods can you
use that same recipe exactly that
100 percent
once it's pickled it doesn't really go
off okay now put them in there so can we
eat this straight away when it's in here
do you know what as soon as it's cooled
down
you can definitely eat that straight
away can't wait to dig into it didn't it
only delicious yes we'll leave that to
cool down our pickles are ready and
cooling now to marinate the chicken on
the Fried Chicken traditionally it's
always going to be done with the dark
meat the brown meat so you've got that
nice sort of drum here and this bit that
thigh cooking on the bone as well keeps
it even more moist so first things first
Salt and Pepper please
buttermilk in it's brilliant for
marinating the chicken if you can put
this buttermilk over your chicken the
night before the more it tenderizes the
chicken and starts to sort of really
relax the chicken and puts a really nice
sort of creamy soury flavor in there so
I might stick that in the fridge first
please and we'll start the dolce de
leche biscuits
call these shortbreads Alpha Jorge and
they're the favorite sweet treat on the
streets of Buenos Aires they're light
crumbly shortbread biscuits sandwiched
with gloriously golden cowly dolce de
leche sauce
for the shortbread beat together
softened butter
granulated sugar
and beat until light and fluffy
add one egg
[Music]
sliced vanilla pods
grape other seeds add to the mix and
beat again
[Music]
sift plain flour
corn flour
and baking powder
then fold the mixture together
using floured hands roll into small
balls flatten into discs and place on a
baking tray
chill for 10 minutes until firm to touch
then simply bake for 10 to 12 minutes or
until pale golden
once cooled
sandwich two biscuits together with a
calmly dolce de leche sauce
finish with a dusting of icing sugar
[Music]
my dessert and pickles are ready the
buttermilk should have worked its magic
on the chicken all that's left is to fry
it
now we're gonna roll the chicken out of
the buttermilk into the flour so that's
why it's nice and crispy and blistery on
the outside Okay cool so what we've got
to make sure because the flour is the
last coat yes this is nicely seasoned
yeah okay so salt and pepper in there
nice
and this is smoked paprika so that gives
a little bit of sort of uh maybe it's
yeah a little bit Yeah spice let's try a
little bit of heat and this one my
favorites what's that cayenne pepper
that's right again slightly spicy but
the heat works brilliantly well
garlic powder traditionally I used a lot
in the steaks onion powder garlic powder
just run your fingers through that
please cool I want to get the pan on now
two centimeters of oil this is a really
good mix for fish as well goujons biting
a nice spicy
texture helps fish so first thing is we
just shake off some of the buttermilk
lay that down yeah okay really important
to get them covered completely okay in
the flour yeah okay so but I love fried
chicken do you
now
lift that up there first one and you
place it in there away from you nice and
gently
okay and lay away good
if any stage you think the oil is
getting too hot yeah just add a touch of
cold oil in there yeah or turn off the
gas
good gently fry the chicken for 25 to 30
minutes or until cooked through now very
carefully turn them over please yeah
every day Jack Fried Chicken every day
no definitely not it's a treat and it's
shallow fried so once every three weeks
yeah sounds great to me yeah now offer
the gas okay yeah paper ready okay onto
the paper
seven oh nice
I love fried chicken pretty sure I love
it look here's the best bit
delicious now
Fried Chicken
pickles if you pick up um Dolton
electric cakes we are ready bud very
nice let's go
delicious mom
Divine dolce de leche biscuits my
pickled celery and buttermilk fried
chicken A Soulful street food Feast if
there ever was one